welcome back to roots and hearts chase
that's good man good day so only about
like an hour or so before you're gonna
perform no we interrupting like your
pre-show rituals like do you do anything
oh absolutely
what are you guys interrupting
completely or the show is probably gonna
be a bad show tonight actually about an
hour before I'll start my thing and it
usually involves a drink up for myself
start relaxing and 45 minutes before the
guys come on the bus we do a prayer a
shot or shot a prayer and then this
chant that's just gotten ridiculous over
the years surely I can every show you do
that every show yeah and the whole bands
on there whoever's on the bus has to
partake in it and it's gotten he's
gotten pretty out of hand it's fun man
we go pretty well with it so what is so
special about being at music festivals
as opposed to doing you know like a show
on tour I mean it's it's what does it
for artists headlining this weekend and
then all the people open it for them so
it's a tour I mean one night you'll get
you know three artists here you get like
a lot more than that yeah and you get
four headlining artists just a crowd
different it's a different feel to it um
yeah yeah for sure though I mean people
are partying harder I think because
they're camping they don't have to leave
out there so they can they can go to
nuts so it's definitely more of a party
I'd say it's just more of a party
atmosphere and that's I like that yeah
and I don't throw on the show but you're
representing the Canadian Kirk Muller
yeah I got a support hand while I'm up
here is that you guys are friends right
yeah yeah except for he beat me in arm
wrestling so some I'm not been talking
to him since then but nah he's a great
guy and yeah I hang out with him all the
time so it's Canada it's becoming home
for us yeah I was we had two three days
off between like we had to go somewhere
and I think in Pennsylvania after our
last Canada show and we went up to his
house and lake house and we're just
riding around the boat drinking you know
playing guitar at night it's just a
relaxing place man especially in the
summer yeah the time to be here for sure
now also the festival we've got this
thing going on the Chevy music presents
boots and hearts emerging out of
showcase so it's a lot of artists that
are trying to get their big break or
just starting
like what advice would you have for
artists that are trying to get that big
breakthrough um I would say just stick
to being yourself yeah don't try to be
some I don't life
don't try to be Sam hunt don't try to be
Thomas Rhett don't try to be me like try
just stick to yourself but then put real
it for me like what I've really learned
a lot lately is just pushing myself to I
know who I am now as an artist I know
what I'm doing with my music but I'm
also pushing the edge and I'll go into a
write and I'll be like yeah that doesn't
sound like something I would do but
let's try it and see what happens and
then it's up to you to put it out I mean
you don't nobody's gonna hear it if you
don't want to so I would just say be
yourself and push push it to the edge
and I feel like to country music is
expanding in terms of the sound do you
think that like the boundaries of
patience acts like I mean I'm Annessa
yeah I don't know what's country wants
not anymore I really don't care I just
love making music I love making my music
and if little Nozick's can can make a
ton of money right I'm gonna change that
kids learning that's gonna change it for
everyone a little bit you can have these
different sounds come in right right and
music like I said it's not all about
money but like that's changing his life
yeah so these people complain insane
he's not country shouldn't be there he
did it yeah so stop being jealous yeah
just enjoy the music um yeah it's for me
it's it's there so I mean you hear like
dan + Shay on pop radio yeah it's an
country radio so it's all over the place
it's a to me the most difficult time in
music because there's so much of it
there's so much traffic it's it's hard
to really break through but if you're
great and you just keep going eventually
you'll get there yeah speaking of going
number one eyes on you
yeah first number one would that feel
like when you found it when number one
um what we knew about probably Wednesday
that was probably gonna get there but it
was awesome
we waited six long years to of touring
of writing and putting music out to to
get a number one and I'd had one as an
artist with crews or as a writer with
ruse but not as an artist so it was
awesome it was awesome for me it was
awesome for the crew we fought for it
and and now we got to do it again that's
the thing like with the song crews like
the Florida Georgia line song and that
one number one was there really really
different feeling to have your own song
that you
yeah way different you're
behind-the-scenes your your collecting a
check at that point as a writer and it's
cool it's an honor you know plaques are
coming in it's a cool thing but as an
artist it's like no this is my face this
is me representing the song so it means
a lot more yeah now you're single lonely
few are yeah I noticed some of the
lyrics in there alluding to the bachelor
yeah
I don't watch them if that's your next
question I watched I watched one season
in high school because my mom washed it
okay Trista and Ryan that's the only two
people from The Bachelor all together
right I think so that's two lasted and
and then I've watched one episode since
then and it was the one where the guy
just jumped the fence all right yeah I
was dating her all the time and she she
was obsessed with she was freaking out
of his I'm packing my stuff like to go
where I'm going that night on the bus
and she's in there like what he just
jumped the fence Jase you gotta get in
here to see this and I'm just like you
guys are crazy
I will say it's addicting I went in
there watched it for a minute I'm like
okay I could see why it's addicting but
I'd rather be addicted to something out
and how does it feel like having that
song right there now it's been a very
right yeah it's a good start it's a best
start we've ever had to any song yeah my
entire career even eyes on you but it's
gonna be a long battle I mean to get it
to get it to number one and fight for
where I believe it deserves to be
because it it's reacting with the fans
and at the end the day number one song
doesn't matter to these people yeah they
just know what they're like so that's
the most important thing to me I just
want to get the most people here in it
most people saying it back so it's got a
long ways to go we got a lot of life
left in that one so it's the beginning
of a new journey but it's gonna be fun
let's thing terms of journey like you
just wrapped one tour this is kind of
almost like a bridge this is our weekend
off yeah Yas on you tour goes right into
the am/pm tour next week and we were
supposed to you know rest this weekend
and this is our version arrests here
boots and ours do you find touring a
grind or is it just I love it I just get
so bored at home so I'm like get me on
the bus let me go yeah
yeah and in terms of lonely few are we
leading towards a new album like what's
the plan
yeah it's works I'm gonna put out some
new music this fall okay um it's
probably not to be full fully produced
I'm just meaning a guitar for some of it
just a different thing I just want to
show people what's coming really so I'm
gonna put you know five or six songs out
this fall that'll be kind of showing
what's what you're gonna hear next year
nice well you got to go get ready
times a-tickin we go so we're in about
our